hello and welcome to a special segment
of GameSpot's play for all now we're not
talking about a new game per se but
we're talking about a game that always
has something new in it but talk about
call of duty modern warfare and war zone
and I have Joe Jeff and Amos join with
me to talk all about what's coming up
with call of duty modern warfare first
thing I want to ask is you're in the
middle of season four and I want to kind
of get a feel for the the state of war
zone like what's going on what things
are changing what players can expect in
your future and things like that
we launched season four I think with
each season we we feel like we're
getting better at it right like when we
launched warzone we didn't know you know
exactly how it was going to go and so
each season we do these kind of Road
roadmaps and we build up what's gonna be
in this season and I feel like with each
season we're getting better so we're
pretty happy with season four we tried
some really unique stuff in this season
warzone Rumble the juggernaut moriah
trial mode we even did 200 players so
these are all things that we kind of
like we put out there and we look for
player feedback we go play them in the
wild and we also look at how popular
they are war zone Rumble has done really
really well a lot of people got in there
had a lot of fun we're able to take in
and level their guns and and kind of
like build out their loadouts 4br for
plunder so that's been it's been really
cool to see and it's been really cool to
kind of experiment what we inject into
the warzone mold when we already have
battle royale and plunder in there we
kind of look at players as different
types right if you're hyper competitive
and any of your player who players want
to explore want to respawn quickly and
so we're always trying to like make sure
they have a place we introduce the new
contraband contract in season 4 which
allows you to take a blueprint out of
the map and keep it permanently as we've
seen players engaging with that we're
excited for future seasons to add new
content they're more opportunity for
players to actually get things in the
warzone environment take them out
permanently put them into loadout so
that sort of thing season four is
interesting to look at as a whole
because it's so it's such a great
offering from where we started like when
we started we only had like trios and
and plunder and now we've got
you know solos duo's trios quads
we've got plunder in there then we
usually have a limited time mode like
Rumble in there and we we've added
things like the public event system you
know where the the loot shoppers come in
and the jailbreak and all these cool
things for adding so what I like to see
is the growth from season to season how
we keep continually adding value to the
free-to-play players we keep it like Joe
said we're looking at different
playstyles when trying to add game modes
and events to kind of hit everybody and
so it's just awesome to see the growth
and to plan out where we're going in the
future that's definitely one of the
fairly I guess new things about Call of
Duty's adapting to the live service
model in many ways because you know the
playlist is gonna be very different even
from from like week to week I hop on and
there's new modes that I even like heard
of or had anticipated so how much
freedom do you have to pivot when you
know modes aren't hitting or when do you
consider to make a mode permanent or not
like can you give me some more insight
on what goes into making these these
wildly different modes I think what we
try and do is put out modes and put them
into like a limited-time fashion to see
how the community reacts so we don't
want to just like put on a mode and
force it down the communities throw it
like you know this is the mode and
you're playing it you're gonna like it
so we'll put up mode to see the
community reacts we could fix things
we'll bring it back it's more about
finding what the community likes and
giving them a variety and bringing him
back and deciding what stays what comes
back is usually very data-driven so it's
a combination of data we see how many
players are jumping in you know how does
it stack up against the current playlist
also like where does the community think
are there changes the community
suggesting that we think would make the
mode play better when we bring it back
so it's a lot about just like putting
out modes and then listening to the
community as a live service and deciding
how many players were in this and what
was the feedback and does this fit a
play style that doesn't already exist
that's it's definitely an exciting part
cuz you never know what you're gonna get
rather than you know jumping in and
simply just doing TDM or realism TDM
which which I tended to do when the game
first came out yeah but yeah there's
there's a lot of variety but there's
also a lot of continual update
I mean that's I guess it's not anything
new for a competitive shooter but recent
Patrick's came out and you've made some
tweets to the weapons specifically the
growl has been changed it's been
unearthed I guess you could say and I
guess that's the one of the highlights
of the latest fixes to the core gameplay
can you where does that come from do you
listen to player feedback specifically
where what are you looking at when you
do core changes to things like that
because we've constantly seen things
maybe not being exploited but we've seen
players kind of use things to their
advantage in maybe ways you had intended
so how are you getting that feedback and
how are you internalizing it I think
it's a mix right like we definitely look
at stats we look at how are the guns
performing one interesting we do
interesting thing we do is we compare
your personal KB with your KD with like
a weapon and it gives us kind of a Delta
and when we say you I mean like on
average everyone like what is the impact
these guns are having um and we use that
to help us kind of balance the weapons
and see where they're at so we also look
at you know there's player sentiment
there's you might look at the eSports
group and see what are they like their
men maxing the game so what are they
running we might look at like recently
we adjusted the no stock on weapons cuz
a lot of players were running these
weapons of like really long barrels with
no stock and they look kind of funky and
the goal there was that people were
taking the no stock for mobility and
hipfire not 80s accuracy so the no stock
wasn't affecting the gun enough and
that's where we're looking at it from a
design standpoint of like what should
this gun be doing given how they're
building it it's not doing what we
intended so let's fix it so we have kind
of like those three avenues of like
stats look at them what what's popular
and then look at what the design was and
then kind of like organize all of that
so going into it with 60 to 70
attachments per gun we kind of knew that
we're gonna have to massage some things
as we go
but um you know I think it's also you
know taking what what is perceived to be
like the medigun and and kind of
smoothing that out so more things are
viable we don't want just the game to be
just this one gone or one one style of
play and try to just make it a broad you
know like we were talking about before
adding to two different play styles and
making sure that you know the game is is
open for a lot of different weapons and
medicine and and we try and be pretty
delicate to like the grout changes
weren't like crazy and some people like
it still too good you know it's good
we nudge it right we nudge it and then
we look at kind of like the stat what do
we do what was the change we definitely
don't want the meta to get stale to be
the same for too long so even if
something was like perfectly balanced
and at some point be like Oh everyone's
playing the same way always we need to
change things up so players approach it
from a different angle because it's no
fun coming in and always playing with
the same exact loadout the same exact
gun after after you know two months or
three months you know we're life service
we want people playing this game for
years and that won't last if if we're
not adding new guns and changing stats
and and kind of you know playing with
the sandbox elements of the mode to get
people to move around differently RDR
you know weapons that we release for
free each season we've been pretty
consistent with three weapons we've
actually added some melee recently with
so now we have four and those are free
base weapons tons of progression
everything in there but we look at those
as shifts of functionality as well
they're not we try not to make them too
derivative we try and inject new
experiences in with those guns as well
season four we're in the middle of it is
there anything that you can share for
the future or the near future of modern
warfare and warzone beyond season 4 like
what are some of the things that you are
looking at and maybe if you want to give
any specific details on season 5 I'm
here for that but I'm not gonna pressure
you but maybe folks might want to know
what kind of big changes they should
expect when new content does roll around
one of the ones we we we've looked at
what we keep trying different weapons in
the in the Gulag and this is something
where like some people have their
different preferences right some people
really like the kind of pistol some
people like the flaw
weapons some people like the snipers
snipers have been a bit controversial
internal controversial is the right way
but there's been a lot of outcry of like
they want that adjusted and so we've
we've looked at making sure that we can
update that more often and not have it
be so static so that's something we're
gonna try rotating like week to week
what the weapons are that are in the
gulag I think that'll be a nice quality
of life change it'll keep that
experience feeling fresh and if
something is in there and it's not you
know being received well we can adjust
more quickly yeah for the future we're
definitely looking at things like just
said to change the meta we're definitely
looking at adding a new kill streak or
two to see how that does we're
definitely looking at adding more public
events people really seem to like those
so we're seeing like you know how far
can we push that because the public
event you know only happens once every
five games and it's kind of a cool thing
and I said I've disruptive so we're
seeing how far we can take that and
bring engagement and change the meta and
make it feel like every every five games
or so you have a cool different new
experience and of course we're gonna
continue to make game modes like we have
but that's sort of the easy answer but
yeah things to change up the meta is
really kind of heading things to
increase that sandbox we really feel
like the sandbox element of the game has
really grabbed onto players you know all
the crazy things you can do with drones
and c4 and vehicles and you know
parachutes and we really want to kind of
expand that sandbox type gameplay as
much as we can now as a player of Call
of Duty I think one of the things that
at least we've seen some progress on is
how to better handle player toxicity
because that does affect the experience
of a lot of players and obviously there
have been moves but things can always be
better and there's it's very hard to
find the best solutions for because of
how how deep it goes but can you speak
to sort of the the things that you're
seeing reflected with new
implementations of trying to curb player
toxicity and what are some of the things
that you still need to work on in that
regard so we launched the game with kind
of like this a TBI user right for cross
and one of the things that we ran into
was the filter system for names and
things like that wasn't up to snuff
because we were handling on our side so
that's that's something we don't one
pretty quickly to improve we added the
kind of report player options and
feedback for players when a report
actually was successful and I think
that's been it's given players a little
bit more power to kind of like help
police and help us and it's and it's
also an ongoing thing like it's
something that with each title update
with each season where we're improving
and we're monitoring I want to ask about
what your plans are moving forward with
war zone with modern warfare and all of
its success and plans when future Call
of Duty's do come out like how do you
square the fact that you're still trying
to support your game and the healthy
player base the fact that there are new
ones in the series coming out alongside
that we still have we know we have
people who love modern warfare and who
are gonna stay with modern warfare and
then that they enjoy war zone so we're
not gonna stop updating we're gonna keep
pushing and moving forward with that
we're also looking at interesting ways
to tie in future iterations with warzone
but we don't have specifics on that
right now we're working through that
yeah I think I think one of the key
things that we realized when we launched
and we've been seeing is that the more
tie ends we have to the premium title
the better it is for everybody the the
players just love like they love the the
the cross progression and they love
going between multiplayer and warzone a
lot of our players play both it's not
it's not really just like I only play
this they look going in and so I think
we're just constantly looking for more
ways to to incorporate as much as we can
to bring players in as to play both
products we really don't want to like
say create this divide you either play
the main title or you play warzone we
want to like say you want to Kerch
players to play everything right and get
the largest player base we can and bring
in new users to warzone and bring in the
premium user stores on it and have
people going back and forth between the
products that's where we've seen the
most success and most engagement so we
just want to continue that philosophy of
like like not putting up walls like
allowing players to go between the games
and share items now I mean I you know
war zone was what is it was specifically
named Call of Duty war zone not you know
modern warfare war zone and and it that
the goal is for it's a kind of merge and
amalgamation from from you know title
the title and and feel like one whole
universe so that's the goal is this is
to tie the whole universe together
reward them okay before I let all of you
guys go is there anything else you want
to add that we may have not touched on
in the previous questions you know we
started off making this crazy game with
modern warfare and made it even crazier
with warzone and everybody that's just
worked really hard on this game it's
awesome to see how many people have come
out and play and you know we've all said
during this conversation you know we're
constantly listening to people and try
to make it better for everyone but we're
super happy that people came out to
check it out yeah I would I would
completely agree with that like we're
thankful both for everyone who worked so
hard on it and and everyone who's come
out to play we took a lot of leaps with
this game with getting rid of the the
season pass and you know functional
items and MTX are out like took we dig a
cross play and it's been it's been a
wild ride free-to-play war zone and so
we're just happy to be happy to be here
and thankful I'm really excited and and
kind of thankful for our community like
they're really active on Reddit and
Twitter and they're constantly giving us
feedback and helping us make the game
better and and I know it doesn't feel
like it because as as sort of like
public figures of the company we can't
always get into reddit and comments like
oh that's a good idea no we're doing
that or like you know we can't we can't
get into those like arguments online
with people and we've got to make the
game right we can't we can't be
distractions but but we are all of us
are on on you know reddit and discord
and Twitter and we're reading the
comments every day and we're listening
people to send a feedback and a lot of
the things we do come from from
community sentiment and feedback so I'm
just like really happy that we have that
active community he's passionate about
it because you can really see their
passion and their ideas and their
thoughts and it's just kind of it's it's
fun to work on something and see it
impact someone
people and and see that people want to
make it better have idea so that that's
really helps me stay engaged alright
so Jeff Amos thank you so much for
joining me this morning to talk about
call of duty modern warfare and call of
duty war zone Thank You oh thank you all
for your time and thanks for talking
shop thank you thank you thanks for
talking to us of course all right and
all of you folks out there watching
thank you so much for your time as well
gamespot has so much more coverage for
play for also be sure to check out all
of our developer interviews and all of
our streams and all of our exclusive
gameplay content and don't forget to
donate to our causes that we are also
supporting links are in the description
below and yes thank you for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you